This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO. percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me.
I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
Listen to look back at it on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that doesn't. not mean that you need to.
Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian.
Michael Mancini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, it's Gemma.
And I have something really special to share with you. I'm hosting my first ever virtual live video podcast. Not a pre-recorded episode, not a highlight. real, but a real time face-to-face moment where we get to connect, laugh, and kind of just reflect together no matter where you are in the world. Plus, I'm hosting a VIP after-party for my inner circle where I will be answering your questions and getting to talk to you guys even more. It's happening August 12th at 7pm Pacific Time or August 13th at 12pm if you live in my hometown of Sydney. You can grab your ticket now at pave.live. I cannot wait to see you there.
Hello everybody and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology. Hello everybody, welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. New listeners, old listeners, wherever you are in the world. It is so great to have you here back for another episode as we of course break down the psychology of our 20s. Today, we are talking about something that has become absolutely mega huge. I would say in like the last year, what we are talking about is the rise of run clubs, run mania, half marathon ambitions, people putting their Strava on their hinge profiles, people's Saturday mornings booked out to run 3K, 5K, 10K, seemingly over night,
running has become like the new frontier of fun and I have to admit I myself have been bit by the running bug and not just like the running bug the run club bug here's the thing I distinctly remember it's a very it's a core memory cool memory for me I remember saying to one of my best friends last year if I join a run club stop me something is wrong like something is wrong this is not me. I've turned down the wrong path. I have always headed running. I would try for a few months, maybe run like max like three kilometers, which is still quite far and then kind of just give up. And I always was like, you know what? Running just isn't for me. I'm just not going to be that kind of gal. Like, it's just not in the cards. Now I'm at a point where I'm running 30 kilometers
a week. I have a running vest. And every Sunday, without fail, I'm at the park at 8.5. am ready to do my three laps with my friends. And I keep thinking back to that person, that version of me, who kind of didn't know what she was missing. I love my run club. And this, it turns out, is no accident. I think especially in our 20s and 30s when loneliness can really creep in quite easily and our identity feels very slippery, there is something quite powerful about showing up for something so simple, so repetitive, so social, and kind of quietly very transformative. You know, you don't need to be fast, you don't need to know anyone, you just need to keep putting one foot in front of the other, and then at the end, you get rewarded with a really
convenient kind of socialization that I don't think a lot of us have experienced since high school or college or maybe like a graduate program. Additionally, I think when some of the earlier structures we relied upon to give our life meaning fall away, running is a really positive and easy space to set goals in. It is very easy if you are capable to see effort directly reflected in performance. You know, you run more, you add more kilometers, you train harder, you will see an improvement. Whereas in other areas of our life, progress, it's a lot harder to track. It's not as not as linear and, you know, of course, exercise also just makes us feel good. So there's like the inherent reward in that as well. So in today's episode, we are going to dive into the
psychology of run clubs and their emotional pool, especially in our 20s and 30s, we're going to talk about their inherent benefits, how they're actually quite positive anchors and what they reveal about how we want to be seen and support and how we want to connect as humans in this decade, we're also going to dive into the downsides. Downsides that I have seen myself, especially when run clubs are not inclusive or they're too image-based and how we can continue to engage in them in a way that serves us without feeling let down by these other elements that have no space in this community. So this one is for all my runners out there, my run curious listeners, maybe even the movement
avoided who are like looking at run clubs thinking that looks awful why would anyone want to do that hopefully this episode gives you kind of an idea so without further ado let's get into the unexpected psychology of run clubs so first off let's answer this very big question why are run clubs suddenly everywhere what has changed in our social fabric that has made the simple act of collectively jogging together such a powerful magnet for community it turns out run clubs are basically filling a very crucial void that we have as a generation that very little else is prepared to fill. Consider this. Many of us in our 20s are experiencing what psychologists would call social displacement. So we are often moving to new cities for jobs.
We are chasing opportunities far from our hometowns. We graduate from university or we finish school or we finish apprenticeship and suddenly we kind of lose those. built-in effortless structures of friendship. You don't have daily class, you don't have campus clubs, you don't have shared dorm rooms. That constant easy proximity to friends, I feel like it almost vanishes overnight and you're suddenly spending a lot more time alone when perhaps you don't really want to. You're trying desperately to build new communities in new spaces, and it's really hard. This is not just you. This is not an isolated experience. There was a 2021 study published in the very famous journal, Nature, and it actually analyzed mobile phone data from
millions of users, and it confirmed that our friendship networks do tend to shrink significantly and quite rapidly during our 20s. This is because we become more selective. Also, it's just, you know, convenience, distance, and the fact that the effort required to forge new friendships, it's really overwhelming when you don't have that base level of knowing each other or similarity. The best name I have for it is a friendship recession and it leaves many of us feeling like a very profound sense of loneliness. Also, despite being really hyper-connected online, spending even more time on our phone, it doesn't really seem to be helping.
We actually are more lonely than ever before. That irony is like not lost on me. You know, we are digitally saturated, but we are relationally starved. Like social media has convinced us that we can be more in contact than ever before, but the level of contact is so shallow. And that is actually a real growing concern. You may have heard the statistic that loneliness is as dangerous as smoking a packet of cigarettes a day. That's a scary figure and for many people in their 20s, that is their reality. This is where run clubs come in. Run clubs offer a really tangible real world antidote to digital fatigue and to social isolation during this decade. We aren't just looking for exercise. Like if you just want it exercise,
you could go to the gym, you could go and run by yourself. It's the human connection, specifically a kind that goes beyond the screen that is really what people want. They're seeking a tribe, they're seeking a place where they belong, and they are also seeking a shared experience with other human beings. Run clubs make all of this easier because they reintroduce structured socialization. Unlike trying to kind of start a conversation with a random person in a coffee shop or at a bar or trying to form connection with people at parties, which, oh my God, honestly, is the worst. I can't even be bought. rather doing that anymore. Run clubs provide like a really low pressure,
predefined environment for connection where the rules of engagement are very, very clear. You are not forced into intense conversations. You can chat during the warm up. You can chat during the run if your pace allows it. During cool downs, you could grab a coffee afterwards. But, you know, the primary activity of running provides a really comfortable backdrop. So it takes the pressure off awkward silences. There's also a number of people there who you can go and run with. If a conversation has a low, you can always just focus on your running, you can play music. You don't have to carry the conversation, basically.
The run kind of does that for you. It's like a version of parallel play, which is a concept in developmental psychology, where basically some of the best kinds of experiences and most joyful experiences we have are when we are just doing something side by side with someone without being fully invested in what the other person is doing, but we get a lot of enjoyment from just kind of having them there. If you think about it as well, you know, this whole idea is built around what you would assume is a common interest. Like, you know that everyone there shares a love of running or at least has a willingness to try. So this breaks down a huge initial barrier. There is immediately something that
you can relate to the other person about. And also, you know, there's a regular schedule as well. so it also introduces predictability, which means the cognitive load and the cognitive effort of having to make plans and having to find the place that's going to work for everyone and the time and whatever, that disappears. You just know where to show up and you know they'll be there and you can opt in or you can opt out. I think in a way someone actually said this to me the other day. It kind of feels like run clubs have replaced like after school clubs for us in our 20s. Like, you know, after school when you used to, like, go and play sport or used to go to, like, like, craft club or, like, I don't know what you guys did.
I used to go to, like, band practice. Like, yeah, it wasn't always the most fun, but it was regular and there were people there and you would make friends through that. This is what a run club is. We're basically just trying to replicate the social scaffolding that we, like, enjoyed about being at school and that we enjoyed about being around people, our own age with similar interests, doing similar things. So this consistent low pressure interaction of run clubs is actually has a name. What we're experiencing when we go to these is what psychologists call incidental intimacy.
It is the kind of familiarity and comfort that develops from just simply sharing routine spaces and sharing activities week after week with the same people, much like those after school clubs. You know, think about your old school friends. As you get older, you kind of realize, like you maybe didn't really like them as much as you thought you did. You probably didn't have much in common, but you did have the shared environment. And so that meant that the repetition of casual exposure and casual interactions already gave you like a very pre-prepared baseline for friendship.
Run clubs recreate this organic environment, and it's something that a lot of people are really craving, and it makes it easier, I think, at least, to transition from running buddy to genuine friend if you have enough of those casual repeated moments with each other. Obviously, that doesn't just provide fertile ground for platonic relationships. It's also a great place to meet people romantically. And that is coming up with run clubs time and time again. I've been seeing this all over TikTok, like, are run clubs, the new day? dating apps? Like, is this where you're going to meet your partner? Like, it seems like it's also
meeting a need in the dating space as well. Not only are we finding it hard to meet friends in real life, obviously, the dating apps are swampy and they suck and people hate them and there's very little success on them. And so run clubs are also filling that space. Like they have this dual ability to fill the need for real human connection where you can like see someone. and be like, do I like you? Do we have chemistry? Are we interested in each other rather than having to go through like, okay, let's talk on Hinge for three weeks and then maybe one day we'll figure it out? A couple of my friends have actually been dating people they met at run clubs. And you know what? It's not just because it's a shared interest and it's not just because it's convenient and because it
facilitates real-world connections. Exercise also famously causes us to release endorphins and dopamine, the happy hormone, which play a really crucial role in the brain's reward system, but also in the development of lovey-dovey romantic feelings. So it's like you're already are meeting people from a place of a natural endorphine high and a level of joy and happiness and openness. So you are more receptive to, I don't know, like a little romantic bond. There's also something to be said about the position of your body when you attend these clubs that naturally lends itself to openness and socializing, not just romantic but platonic as well. There's something very primal about moving in sync with others.
that kind of collective motion synchronized movement that comes from running together, it is an incredibly natural way of being for us as humans. And it promotes affiliation. It promotes trust. There's been research into this that shows that when we engage in coordinated physical activities, our sense of cooperation improves. It can even reduce pain sensitivity among participants because we know that. that community and feeling like we're part of a collective is incredibly healing and nourishing
and it's something we don't have enough of. It's also partly due to the role of mirror neurons. You've probably heard of these before. Mirror neurons are these specialized brain cells that fire both when we perform an action and when we observe someone else performing the same action like running. Interestingly, these mirror neurons, what is to blame, like when you see someone else yawn and we ourselves yawn, it's basically like the building block for empathy and for allowing us to have a shared experience of the world and allowing us to feel bonded to other people. So when you're running alongside someone, you're matching their pace, you're feeling the same exertion, your mirror neurons are firing like crazy and they are creating a subconscious bond of empathy,
understanding and camaraderie. I know that sounds strange, but scientifically, you know, this side-by-side dynamic is actually a really important part of run clubs that people don't often talk about. Also, there's a lack of eye contact, right? So having someone next to you means you don't have to have that sustained focus and attention on the other person that happens when you sit down for coffee or you sit down for dinner. And that actually really lowers the expectations and it creates a low pressure environment that does make it easier to share thoughts, to be vulnerable, to share personal stories. Therapists and counselors actually take advantage of this a lot. This is the principle behind walk and talk
therapy where therapists understand that when you're walking with someone outdoors side by side, actually the likelihood that someone will disclose something or the likelihood that someone will feel comfortable enough to share is increased because it reduces inhibition between the client and the therapist. So are run clubs also the new therapy? No, but kind of when we consider these principles, these building blocks of intimacy and vulnerability that are shared between therapy, between relationships, between bonds and empathy, and all these things are bringing people into the run club fold. And I think that's why they are so fantastic for people struggling with loneliness and their mental health. Like this low stakes environment,
the fact that our attention can be directed towards something else does mean that you don't have to put as much effort and energy into trying to chat people up or trying to talk to people when you are otherwise feeling incredibly drained. But, of course, their benefits do go far beyond simply filling our social calendar. They also tap into some brilliant psychological mechanisms that actively boost our well-being on an individual scale. So we are going to take a short break, but when we return, we're going to talk about these individual benefits and also maybe some of the downsides that we need to be aware of.
So stay with us. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%, I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more, to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominate. the wellness industry.
We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's T-W-O-Persent on the I-Hart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking.
What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam Jek. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we picket here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crows. crack.
I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so y'all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you finishing that sentence. Yes. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really?
Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hardway with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Keer Games. And in recognition of Mental Health Awareness Month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking, Tript Fontaine, Ryan Clark.
Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it. And we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth?
Are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Kear Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose
on my new podcast, learn the hard way. Open your free, our heart radio app. Search learn the hard way and listen now. In 2023, former bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in someone, correct? I doctored the test ones.
It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Alespian and Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young.
This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Maricopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until Justice of. is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
Anyone who has ever tried to kind of stick to a solo exercise routine knows that it is very, very tough. You could probably do it, but it's not as enjoyable or perhaps as motivating or there's not as much accountability as when you exercise with other people. And that is where run clubs have a massive, psychological advantage in terms of motivation. The mere presence of other people when we are exercising has been shown time and time again in research to boost physical performance. This is known as social facilitation. Running with a group can make you push yourself harder, can make you maintain a
faster pace, and it can just simply help with showing up when you otherwise may have skipped your run. I know personally, I run so much better when I'm with you. I'm with you. others because I kind of forget what I'm doing. My friend Maddie and I, we've actually realized are the exact same pace. Like, she's a member of my run club. And when we're running, like, we have this rule in our run club that we don't have to run together and we kind of just meet back at the end for coffee. But me and her always are like within a meter of each other. And I often run so much further. And I feel like I can maintain a much steadier pace because she is by my side. You know, when you're on your own, there is so much opportunity for self-doubt,
but when you're with others, it's like a positive form of fear pressure because you're like, oh my gosh, here is this example right in front of me of someone proving to me that this is possible and that I am also perhaps capable of doing this. Also, a fun fact for you, achieving milestones as a group actually feels more rewarding than achieving a milestone alone. And so the reward is sweeter when you do run further, run faster and someone is doing it with you. And that reward is what sustains effort over time and what sustains people kind of coming back for more. This is where the concept of the social cure actually comes in. I love this concept.
It's one that I talk about so much in my personal life. It was developed by psychologist Alex Haslin and Michelle Ryan. and the social cure theory basically posits that belonging to meaningful social groups, it's not just a nice feeling. It can actually fundamentally determine your physical and mental health. When we strongly identify with a group, it provides meaning and purpose when there is a shared identity, goals, there's social support. That physical network of people can actually change our health status.
it can really boost our self-esteem as well and it can really minimize symptoms or not minimize but reduce symptoms of anxiety and depression. We see this time and time again in different communities and different cohorts of people. When you have more than one social group that you belong to, you feel so supported that your body actually is able to take itself out of survival mode, is able to heal itself, is able to just be more present. Run clubs are an example of this. When you go from I Run to I am a runner with this run club, with the Utah Run Group, with the Slow Girls Run Club,
with the anti-social run club, whatever it is, that social identity becomes incredibly powerful. This also taps into a very famous idea called Third Spaces. So third spaces is like an idea that was first kind of labeled by a sociologist, not a psychologist, a sociologist called Ray Oldenberg. And to explain it is basically this. We have our first spaces. That's your home.
We have second spaces. That's like our workplace or our school. Third spaces are what is really crucial for our mental health. These are these crucial informal public gathering places. that foster community and social interaction and belonging beyond our primary daily obligations. So think coffee shops, think local pubs, think community centres, bookstores or run clubs. Third spaces are so crucial to us because they provide a positive neutral ground to meet others. that isn't really ever that hierarchy or specific social role that you would perhaps need to take on at work or even at home.
So this often gives way to spontaneous interactions and friendships and excitement. And it's in these spaces that you're kind of allowed to be whoever you want to be. I saw this really fascinating article that was published on the site Medium, where the author kind of talked about how third spaces bring back the joy of just, being. So in the article, the author talks about how for a lot of us, the pandemic almost blended our first and second spaces together. A lot of us started working from home. A lot of us became remote workers. Home and work life got really, really mixed up. It was hard to distinguish what identity you were holding at any given time. With this new dynamic as well, it often made
people feel quite monotonous. It felt like they were isolated, they were stuck in their routine and that is still going on to this day. Third spaces though and the reason everyone is being driven toward third spaces, especially after the pandemic and the lockdowns, is because they want to just enjoy being present in a space where there isn't any obligation and where they can just show up as themselves and also just talk to other people and feel like, okay, I'm out of my routine, I've kind of slipped the mask off, I'm just allowed to be. So there's a South Korean philosopher as well called Bang Chul Khan, and he talks about this as the concept of duration. So duration as a concept is basically like his antidote to constantly chasing our future.
He basically says that we, more than anything else, I kind of don't agree with that, but in his words more than anything else, we need a break from the rush and the panic of modern life. If we can carve out space and spaces and time in which we can just enjoy doing something for the sake of doing it, or if we can just create ease and appreciation for the moments we get to spend on things that aren't tied to productivity or career progression, we will be a healthier species. We will love each other more. We will love the planet more. It's a big call to say that wrong clubs are a contribution to that, but there is evidence that they most certainly are because they provide people with this break from their reality that allows them to feel,
他基本上是说，最重要的是，虽然我对此有点保留，但用他的话说，最重要的是，我们需要从现代生活的匆忙和恐慌中抽离出来。如果我们能开辟出一些空间和时间，让我们仅仅为了做一件事而去做这件事，或者如果我们能在那些与生产力和职业发展无关的事情上创造轻松感和对它们的欣赏，我们会成为一个更健康的物种。我们会更爱彼此。我们会更爱这个地球。说跑步俱乐部对此有所贡献可能有些夸张，但有证据表明它们确实做到了，因为它们为人们提供了一种摆脱现实的喘息机会，让他们能够感受到，
I don't know, almost human again, and that allows them to feel like they are someone beyond what people expect them to be. So a lot of philosophy, a lot of sociology, a lot of psychology, all coming together. It's so funny, like perhaps when you started this episode, you were like, wow, run clubs can't be that deep. And now we're talking about how, they contribute to the meaning of life. But I promise there's research. Like there's so much research on this. Let's now move into the shadows of this. Are run clubs just a phase? Are they just a fad? Are they just a trend? Some might argue that their recent surge is simply, as we were saying, a post-pandemic rebound. And the reason they are so popular is because they kind of came up at the right
我不知道，几乎重新找回了人性，这让他们觉得他们不仅仅是别人期望中的那个样子。所以，很多哲学、社会学、心理学，都在这里交融。这太有趣了，就像当你开始听这一集时，你可能会想，哇，跑步俱乐部没那么深奥吧。但现在我们正在讨论它们如何为生命的意义做出贡献。但我向你们保证，是有研究的。这方面的研究真的很多。现在让我们来探讨一下这背后的阴暗面。跑步俱乐部只是一种阶段性现象吗？它们只是一阵狂热吗？只是一种潮流吗？有些人可能会认为，它们最近的激增正如我们刚才所说的那样，是疫情后的一种反弹。它们之所以如此受欢迎，是因为它们恰好在人们经历长期隔离后极度渴望社交的正确时刻
time when a lot of people are desperate for connection after prolonged isolation. I think whilst the pandemic definitely amplified the need for what run clubs offer, they are also still fulfilling and offering solutions to longstanding societal issues that will mean that them or some version of them will probably stick around for a long time. However, a trend can only become a sustainable cultural shift if it continues to meet fundamental human needs in an adaptive way. So this isn't necessarily a concern that run clubs are going to disappear, but that some iterations might lose their core community focus if they become overcommercialized,
应运而生。我认为，虽然疫情确实放大了对跑步俱乐部所能提供的服务的需求，但它们同时也仍在满足和提供长期存在的社会问题的解决方案，这意味着它们或某种形式的它们可能会长期存在下去。然而，一种潮流只有在以适应性方式继续满足人类基本需求的情况下，才能成为一种可持续的文化变革。因此，这并不一定意味着人们担心跑步俱乐部会消失，而是担心某些迭代形式如果过度商业化，
exclusive or focus purely on performance metrics. If every run club is sponsored by Nike, if every run club has a series of Instagram models promoting them online, they have lost their touch and they have lost their accessibility. There is this idea that a club like a run club can only get so big before people start to create their own smaller versions. Once they reach 200 plus people, perhaps even lower, like you no longer can kind of know everyone and you no longer feel like
排外或者纯粹关注表现指标，可能会失去其核心的社区凝聚力。如果每个跑步俱乐部都由耐克赞助，如果每个跑步俱乐部都有一系列Instagram模特在网上为他们宣传，他们就失去了初心，失去了亲和力。有一种观点认为，像跑步俱乐部这样的俱乐部，规模只能扩大到一定程度，人们就会开始创建自己的小型版本。一旦人数达到200人以上，甚至更少，你就再也无法认识每个人了，你也再也无法感觉
you can interact with everyone and you do feel like there's more of a spotlight effect on you. I think a significant potential pitfall that I've personally seen is, again, the lack of, lack of inclusivity. You know, run clubs, despite their open-door appearance, I think can sometimes unintentionally or intentionally become really harmful. if they're not genuinely inclusive and if there's this idea that you have to look a certain way or have a certain pace or be a certain kind of athlete to join them. Now, I'm not saying that there can't be run clubs where people are setting incredible paces, but you have to be clear that that's their intention and that this is the kind of standard
你能与每个人互动，而且你会觉得聚光灯效应更加集中在你身上。我认为我个人见过的另一个潜在的重大陷阱，依然是缺乏包容性。你知道，跑步俱乐部尽管表面上敞开大门，但我认为有时会有意无意地变得非常具有伤害性。如果它们不是真正具有包容性的，如果存在这样一种观念：你必须长成某种样子、拥有某种配速，或者成为某种特定类型的运动员才能加入它们。现在，我并不是说不能有那种大家都在刷新惊人配速的跑步俱乐部，但你必须明确这正是他们的宗旨，而且这就是设定的
that is set. But there have been some videos doing the rounds recently, you guys may have seen some of them, where people are kind of shaming people who show up to run clubs and don't fit the part. I saw one video in particular where members of a particular run club were talking about their running icks and they kind of mentioned things that aren't involved in running. They're basically like, oh, when people show up with their shitty new balance or when they're wearing a running best for like their short run or blah, blah, blah, blah, blah. I saw another video the other day that was like, if your pace is below 10 kilometres and an hour. That's not a run club. That's a walk club. And actually, guys, to kind of stir the pot,
标准。但最近网上流传着一些视频，大家可能也看过其中的一些，视频中有些人有点在羞耻那些来参加跑步俱乐部却不符合要求的人。我特别看到这样一个视频，某个跑步俱乐部的成员在谈论他们的跑步雷区，他们提到了一些与跑步本身无关的事情。他们基本上是说，哦，当人们穿着土气的全新百伦鞋出现时，或者当他们在短距离跑步时穿着跑步背心时，或者诸如此类的话。我前几天还看到另一个视频，上面说：如果你的一公里配速低于10分钟，那不叫跑步俱乐部，那叫走路俱乐部。事实上，伙计们，为了挑起事端，
I saw someone who I know like that video who runs a so-called inclusive fitness club slash inclusive run club. Like, I kid you not, I saw that this person had liked it and I was like, I'm never going to that run club again. I was like, no, I'm not going to show up because here is this person who like at face value is talking about inclusivity. And then their like online behaviours are obviously reflecting that. their values are quite different. I think basically like a run club cannot claim to be something that it is not without incidentally hurting people who might want a gateway into fitness.
我看到一个我认识的人点赞了那个视频，那个人经营着一个所谓的包容性健身俱乐部兼包容性跑步俱乐部。真的不瞒你说，我看到这个人点赞了，当时我就想：我再也不去那个跑步俱乐部了。我想，不，我再也不会去了，因为就是这个人，表面上在谈论包容性，但他们的网络行为显然反映出，他们的价值观完全不同。我认为基本上，一个跑步俱乐部不能标榜自己是什么样的，却无意中伤害了那些可能想要以此作为健身入门途径的人。
Like you cannot say that you have an inclusive run club if someone shows up and they finish and no one is there waiting for them or if someone shows up and they aren't included in the main group and are running behind. I think a run club should always have someone who is part of the team who does not care what their pace is. Their only job is to be the last person in the group. So no one ever feels like, oh, okay, I could just stop running right now and leave and no one would worry about where I was. And no one would worry about if I'm even here. Like that is not the social antidote that run clubs are meant to offer and that they're meant to be.
就像你不能说你有一个包容性的跑步俱乐部，结果有人来参加并完成了跑步，却发现没有人站在终点等他们，或者有人来参加却被排斥在主力团队之外，只能落在后面跑步。我认为跑步俱乐部应该永远有团队成员垫底，他们不在乎你的配速是多少。他们的唯一工作就是做团队里的最后一个人。这样就不会让人觉得：“哦，好吧，我现在就可以停下来离开，根本没人会在意我在哪里，也没人在乎我究竟在不在。”这绝对不是跑步俱乐部应该提供、也本该成为的社交解药。
Also, I think like any social group, very tight-knit clicks can form in these groups. can make it really hard for newcomers to kind of break in and feel a sense of belonging. And this is even harder if a club primarily attracts a homogenous demographic. For example, people from the same race, socioeconomic demographic age or people who, you know, have a certain style or a certain vibe or a certain way of communicating or connecting that isn't always welcoming and isn't always fair. And I'm trying not to give it any more names than that. But I think when I explain it, you know the kind of situation I'm explaining, right? The kind of people who don't make other people feel welcome.
另外，我认为就像任何社交群体一样，这些群体内部很容易形成非常紧密的小圈子。这会让新来者很难融入并产生归属感。如果俱乐部主要吸引的是单一的人口统计群体，这就更难了。例如，来自相同种族、社会经济背景、年龄段的人，或者那些你知道的、拥有某种特定风格、某种特定氛围、某种不总是那么热情和公平的沟通或联系方式的人。我尽量不再给它起更多的名字了。但我想当我这样解释时，你一定知道我在说什么情况对吧？就是那种不会让其他人感到受欢迎的人。
And it's not just that you risk making your run club in exclusive. And it's not just that you risk exacerbating someone else's loneliness. You also risk them not coming back to any run club in the future or any kind of group exercise. You run the risk of, you run the risk of, you run the risk of, of also ruining this person's relationship with physical activity in general and seeing themselves as someone who, you know, exercise isn't made for and enjoying fitness and enjoying movement, that's not for them. And if you can hear the passion in my voice, it's because I feel like I was made to feel like that so often when I was a teenager and even like, even when I was a kid, like, you know, you're, you don't belong there because you don't fit in with however
这不仅仅是你让你的跑步俱乐部变得排他的风险。也不仅仅是你加剧了别人孤独感的风险。你还冒着让他们未来不再参加任何跑步俱乐部或任何形式的集体锻炼的风险。你冒着——你冒着——你冒着彻底毁掉这个人对体育锻炼的总体认知的风险，让他们觉得自己是那种“运动不适合自己，享受健身和享受运动不属于自己”的人。如果你能听到我声音里的激情，那是因为当我还是个青少年，甚至还是个孩子的时候，我常常被灌输这种感觉：“你知道的，你不属于这里，因为你和做这件事的其他任何人看起来都不一样。”
else looks who is doing this. So sorry, I'm going to get off my soapbox, but it does really bother me when I see communities online who say that they're inclusive and who are like, have all the merch and have all the branding. And then you rock up and it's like, oh, okay. So this, you don't really want me here. Like, you don't want me here. And that's okay. Just like make your Instagram private then. Like don't post these big announcements of being like inclusive run club. Everyone show up if you're not going to wait for the last person in line and if you're not going to say hi and welcome new people. Moving on from that, I'm sorry, I've spent too much time on that. Moving on, I think something else can also start to happen that is equally insidious,
所以抱歉，我要从我的讲台上下来了，但每当我看到网上那些标榜自己具有包容性、拥有各种周边商品和品牌标识的社群，结果你一去却发现：“哦，好吧，原来你们根本不欢迎我。”这真的让我很困扰。就像你并不欢迎我一样。那也没关系，那就把你的Instagram设为私密账号好了。既然你不会等待队伍中的最后一个人，也不会打招呼并欢迎新成员，那就别发这种声势浩大的“包容性跑步俱乐部，人人可参与”的公告了。言归正传，对不起，我在这个话题上花的时间太多了。接着说，我认为另一件同样阴险的事情也开始发生，
which is that there is the potential to fall into a comparison trap when running becomes this thing that everyone is obsessed with and everyone is obsessed with optimizing, even something as wholesome as group running can morph into a form of performance, especially when we add in platforms like Strava, for example. Strava, if you don't know what it is, it's basically social media for running where people can, social media for like endurance sports or exercise where you can post the activities you've been doing and it gives you stats on your pace and calories burned and people can give you kudos and whatever. Fantastic tool. I have Strava. I use it for tracking progress. I use it for celebrating achievements. I use it for connecting with my friends. But when every run becomes a
那就是当跑步成为每个人都痴迷的事物，并且每个人都痴迷于优化它时，我们很容易陷入一种比较的陷阱。甚至连集体跑步这样健康的事情也会演变成一种展示表现的形式，特别是当我们加入像Strava这样的平台时。Strava，如果你不知道它是什么，它基本上就是跑步的社交媒体，人们可以在上面分享耐力运动或锻炼的社交媒体，你可以在上面发布你一直在进行的活动，它会为你提供关于配速和卡路里消耗的统计数据，人们可以给你点赞等等。非常棒的工具。我有Strava。我用它来追踪进度。我用它来庆祝成就。我用它来和朋友保持联系。但是当每一次跑步都变成了一份
public record, when every personal best is measured against another, and every workout is kind of tagged and shared and, you know, located to your area, it can really shift the focus from internal enjoyment to just being another avenue for performance. I have a friend who is literally training for the New York City Marathon and who doesn't use Strava for this very reason. This is a direct feed into social comparison theory where we often evaluate ourselves relative to others. We can't help it. We cannot help it. When these comparisons primarily upward, so you compare yourself to someone who is fitter, faster, seemingly more of an effortless runner, they can trigger feelings of inadequacy and envy and the pressure to do
公开记录，当每一个个人最好成绩都被用来与他人进行衡量，每一个锻炼都被打上标签并分享，甚至定位到你所在的区域时，它真的会将焦点从内在的享受，转变为仅仅是展示表现的又一条途径。我有一个朋友正在为纽约马拉松进行艰苦的训练，而他正是因为这个原因才不使用Strava的。这直接导向了社会比较理论，在这个理论中，我们经常将自己与他人进行评估。我们情不自禁。我们真的控制不住。当这些比较主要是向上比较时——也就是说，你把自己和一个更健康、更快、看起来跑步毫不费力的人进行比较——它们会引发不安全感和嫉妒感，以及付出
more to try harder, an overall need to do better, which if you're just there for fun, isn't always helpful. At 2022 study from researchers in the Netherlands, they actually used publicly available data from Strava to look into running behavior. And in total, they looked at five different Strava run clubs with over 300 members, and they found the more kudos runners received on their activities, the more likely they were to run more and more often, and actually the more likely they were to be injured. So yes, kudos fuels our momentum. You can also fuel some other things as well. I think the question then becomes, why am I doing this?
更多、更努力的压力，一种全面表现更好的需求。如果你只是为了好玩而去，这并不总是有帮助。荷兰研究人员在2022年的一项研究中，实际使用了Strava上公开可用的数据来研究跑步行为。总共，他们研究了5个不同的Strava跑步俱乐部，拥有超过300名成员，他们发现跑步者在他们的活动中获得的赞越多，他们跑步的次数就越多、越频繁，事实上他们受伤的可能性也越大。所以是的，点赞确实能推动我们的动力。但它也会助长一些其他的事情。我想随之而来的问题是，
Am I doing it for me or am I doing it for a version of me that I want others to see? And if it is the latter, this can really transform a very joyful activity into a performance and then you kind of do lose the genuine psychological benefits of movement and community because they are overshadowed by anxiety, about pace anxiety, about distance, about appearance, about like the relentless pursuit of what it looks like online. Basically what I'm trying to say is that when health becomes identity, your worth can become tied to your performance metrics. And I think run clubs with their emphasis on physical achievement at times and visible fitness,
我为什么要这么做？我是为了自己而做，还是为了一个我希望别人看到的版本的自己而做？如果是因为后者，这真的会把一项非常快乐的活动变成一场表演，然后你就会失去运动和社群带来的真正的心理益处，因为它们被对配速的焦虑、对距离的焦虑、对外表的焦虑，以及对网络上呈现出来的形象的不懈追求给掩盖了。基本上我想说的是，当健康成为一种身份认同，你的自我价值就会与你的表现指标挂钩。我认为跑步俱乐部对身体成就和外在健康的强调有时，
which isn't a bad thing on its own, but when that's taken too far, it can inadvertently feed into this feeling. The danger isn't about being healthy. The danger isn't in the social aspect. It's in the obsession with optimized health as a defining characteristic of your self-worth that can sometimes easily blossom and bloom. these spaces. Like I, for example, I know that I could never be in an ultra-competitive run group. In fact, like I said, my run club, like we don't even run together. We don't compare paces.
这本身并不是一件坏事，但当这种强调过度时，它可能会无意中助长这种感觉。危险并不在于保持健康。危险也不在于社交层面。危险在于将“优化的健康”痴迷为定义你自我价值的特征，这种心态有时很容易在这些空间里滋生和盛开。比如我，我知道我永远不可能加入一个超级竞争性的跑步小组。事实上，正如我所说，我的跑步俱乐部，我们甚至都不一起跑步。我们不比较配速。
We don't compare times. I know that I could not be in an environment where it felt like a race because I would push myself way too far and I would feel terrible and I would not enjoy the sport anymore. And I feel like the reason that I've been able to improve as much as I have in the last year, because I have been so focused on just enjoying it. I don't have a running schedule. If I don't want to run, I'm not going to do it. And if I find myself comparing to other people's paces, like I immediately shut it down because I feel like everything else in my life, I kind of defined by metrics and I kind of defined by how good am I doing it relative to others and how satisfied do I feel and what should I be doing? I want running to continue to be something that I
我们不比较时间。我知道我无法身处那种感觉像是一场比赛的环境中，因为我会把自己逼得太紧，我会感觉糟糕透顶，我也不会再享受这项运动了。我觉得我在过去的一年里能够取得这么大进步的原因，是因为我一直专注于享受它。我没有跑步日程表。如果我不想跑，我就不跑。如果我发现自己在与别人的配速进行比较，我会立刻制止它，因为我觉得我生活中的其他一切，似乎都由指标来定义，似乎都由“我相对于别人做得有多好、我感到有多满足、我应该做什么”来定义。我希望跑步能继续成为一件我
want to be doing. So with that in mind, we are going to take one more short break, but afterwards, we're going to talk about how to find a run club that's right for you, even if you thought you never were going to be a part of a run club, and how to kind of remember why you started to maintain that joy in the activity itself. Stay with us. Two percent. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2%, I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts,
真正想做的事。考虑到这一点，我们要进行最后一个简短的休息，但之后，我们将讨论如何找到适合你的跑步俱乐部，即使你以前认为自己绝不会加入跑步俱乐部；以及如何记住你最初为什么出发，从而保持对活动本身的乐趣。请继续收听。百分之二。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特，在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析精神坚韧、健身以及在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中建立韧性的科学。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康与健身专家对话，
and more to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the results. of stress. Put yourself through some hardships and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tapped Little Kim's
还有更多人，带大家看穿主导健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们曾深信种子油生来就会引起炎症。我们错了。我们在世界上感到恐慌的许多问题，其实都是压力的结果。经历一些磨难，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听《2%》。也就是IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方的“TWO percent”。你还记得黛安娜·罗斯在VMA颁奖典礼上双击小肯姆的
boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do a little bit? Kim, well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam Jay. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but yeah, yeah, literally. But just so y'all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now.
胸部吗？或者坎耶说乔治·布什不喜欢黑人时？我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什和小肯姆有什么关系？好吧，你可以在《Look Back at it》播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·杰伊。我是亚历克斯·英格利什。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何熬过这段时期的。包括最近一集请来了马克·拉蒙特·hill，大谈80年代的快克毒品。坦白说，84年对我很重要，不仅仅是因为毒品。我随时都可以聊毒品，真的，真的。但只是想让你们知道。我是说，马克，这是我们讨论毒品的第二集了。所以我开始看出一条贯穿始终的主线了。我们现在也把“艾滋病”摆上台面了。
Thank you for finishing that sentence. Yes. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games.
谢谢你把那句话说完。是的。我不认为对黑人来说还有比这更重要的一年了。真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人而言最重要的一年之一。请在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back at it》。欢迎收听我的新播客《Learn the Hard Way》，我是你的主持人，也是你最喜欢的治疗师科尔·盖恩斯。
And in recognition of Mental Health Awareness Month, I'm bringing over a decade. of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking. Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing.
为了纪念心理健康意识月，我带来了十多年的心理健康领域经验，以及与许多不可思议的嘉宾的对话。我说的是。特里普·方丹、瑞安·克拉克。有时我们在追求某事时，会过于陷入追逐的过程，以至于没有意识到我们其实已经拥有了它。
And we're still chasing it. And we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross. Because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth. Are you a good person because you're afraid?
而我们却还在继续追逐。并且我们不知道什么时候才算够了。因为人们总是在盯着记分牌。生活成了关于输赢的游戏。史蒂夫·伯恩斯、达斯汀·罗斯。因为你觉得在人间做个好人很重要。你是个好人是因为你害怕吗？
Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Kear Gaines, is we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, Learn the Hardway. Open your free, Our Heart Radio app.
因为那是两种不同的动机，兄弟。绝对是。而且这是两个不同层面的信任。我希望你能真正地做一个好人。和我科尔·盖恩斯一起，在我的新播客《Learn the Hardway》中，进行关于疗愈、成长、父职、压力和目标的真实对话。打开你免费的IHeart Radio应用程序，
Search Learn the Hardway and listen now. In 2023, former Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in so much, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case.
搜索《Learn the Hard Way》并立即收听。2023年，前《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德发现自己卷入了一场亲子鉴定丑闻。随后的家庭法庭听证会揭露了他故事中明显的矛盾之处。这引发了长达数年的法律战来证明真相。你曾两次篡改了这个特定的测试，对吗？我篡改了一次测试。这动用了大批互联网侦探才破了案。
I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian, and Michael Marincini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap.
我想让人们看到他们的纳税都被用在了哪里。阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们将揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男士。格雷格、一个同性恋者和迈克尔·马林西尼。我的大脑都要炸了。我是斯蒂芬妮·扬。这是《Love Trap》。
Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. I think the final question of the day is, how do we engage with run clubs or with any wellness friend for that matter in a way that is truly healthy, sustainable, and genuinely joyful? It's all about intentionality and I think remembering why you started.
劳拉，斯科茨代尔警方。随着节季的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临了后果。女士们先生们，马里科帕县的突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯因欺诈罪被起诉。在正义在亚利桑那州伸张之前，这一切都不会结束。请在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。我想今天最后一个问题是：我们该如何参与跑步俱乐部，或者就此而言，参与任何健康社群，才能做到真正健康、可持续且发自内心地快乐？这一切都关乎初心，我认为就是要记住你最初为什么出发。
Firstly, try and find the right run club for you. If you really dig into your reason for joining a run club, what comes up? do you want to push for a PB? There are run clubs for that. Do you want to work out in a relaxed atmosphere? There are run clubs for that. Do you want to be competitive with others? Or do you want a run club where you just actually get to maybe sometimes walk and chat with other people? There are run clubs for that. You know, it's really about seeking out a group that emphasizes the shared experience and the shared goal. And just kind of reflecting on the fact that just because a run club wasn't for you doesn't mean that there isn't a better one out there, I'm also a proponent of just
首先，试着找到适合你的跑步俱乐部。如果你深入挖掘自己加入跑步俱乐部的原因，会浮现出什么？你想冲刺个人最好成绩吗？有专门为此设立的跑步俱乐部。你想在轻松的氛围中锻炼吗？有专门为此设立的跑步俱乐部。你想和别人竞争吗？还是你想要一个跑步俱乐部，在那里你实际上可以偶尔和别人一起散步聊天？有专门为此设立的跑步俱乐部。你知道，这其实就是去寻找一个强调共同体验和共同目标的群体。并反思这样一个事实：仅仅因为一个跑步俱乐部不适合你，并不意味着外面没有更好的。我也支持
creating your own run club. You would be surprised at how many people in your life have secretly always thought that they could be a runner. And the thing is that they absolutely could be. It's just so boring when you have to try and do it by yourself. So if you want to make your own run club, like just start by showing up at a time and a place every single Saturday, Sunday, Friday, whatever it is, and just invite people to join you. Like that's really how our run club formed. And oh my God, I'm such a big fan of our run club. It is so inclusive.
创建你自己的跑步俱乐部。你会惊讶地发现，你生活中有多少人其实一直暗暗觉得自己也能成为一名跑步者。事实是，他们绝对可以。只是当你必须一个人咬牙坚持时，实在是太无聊了。所以如果你想创建自己的跑步俱乐部，那就从每周六、周日、周五或任何你选择的时间和地点出现开始，然后邀请大家加入你。这真的是我们的跑步俱乐部成立的方式。天哪，我太喜欢我们的跑步俱乐部了。它真的太包容了。
Everyone has separate goals, but it's just like we are there to have fun. And what it really started as was one friend of ours, our friend Michelle, the one who was training for the New York marathon. She was running a lot because she's training for a marathon. and our other friend Sarah joined her one day. And then I ran into them and then I joined them. And then we've just slowly invited people to come along. And it is a thing we do every Sunday.
每个人都有各自的目标，但我们聚在一起就是为了开心。它最初其实是由我们的一个朋友开始的，我们的朋友米歇尔，也就是那个在为纽约马拉松进行训练的人。她因为要备战马拉松所以经常跑步，有一天我们的另一个朋友萨拉加入了她。然后我遇到了他们，我也加入了。接着我们慢慢地邀请其他人一起加入。现在这成了我们每周日都会做的一件事。
We also have walk club on Thursday. And it just means that we basically just get to hang out. And I feel like in the other run clubs I have tried. I just was like, I want to get out of here. I want to leave. So if you can't find a group that works for you, make your own. I think related to this as well, and I think it's really important to do this, is to regularly check in with your intrinsic motivation. Intrinsic motivation, I think we've talked about this on
我们周四还有散步俱乐部。这意味着我们基本上就是聚在一起闲逛。我觉得在我尝试过的其他跑步俱乐部里，我总是只想离开这里。我只想走。所以如果你找不到适合你的群体，那就自己建一个。我认为与之相关且非常重要的一点是，要经常审视你的内在动机。内在动机，我想我们在
the podcast before, is the highest, most purest form of motivation. It is the motivation that comes purely from the joy of the activity and the joy you get out of it without anyone else's input. So ask yourself, are you running because you genuinely enjoy the movement? Are you running because you enjoy the feeling of getting stronger and the fresh air or as a way to connect with your body, or is it primarily driven by external validation, by comparison, or a rigid sense of obligation? That obligation part, especially, is the easiest way for you to never want to run ever again. If you say to yourself, you have to run and you have to do this and you have to meet that person's pace and you have to hit 10 kilometres on Strava every single.
之前的播客中讨论过，是最高、最纯粹的动机。它是纯粹源于活动本身的乐趣以及抛开任何其他人的干扰时你从中获得的快乐的动机。所以问问自己：你跑步是因为你真心享受运动吗？你跑步是因为你享受变得更强壮的感觉、呼吸新鲜空气，或者把它作为与身体连接的一种方式？还是它主要是由外部认可、攀比或一种僵化的责任感所驱动的？尤其是“责任感”这部分，是让你再也不想跑步的最快途径。如果你对自己说，你必须跑步，你必须这样做，你必须赶上那个人的配速，你必须每个星期在Strava上完成10公里，
week, yes, there is such thing as a goal, but if you're like, you should, otherwise, you deserve to feel guilty and you don't have any room for explanation or excuses, watch yourself fall out of love with that thing so quickly. It's something that we see time and time again in any single space or any single hobby or any single area of life. If it is the latter, I think just take a break and try and return to the natural rhythms of your body and the natural desire cycle of your body, only run when you feel like you really want to and when you're excited to do it. And always run a distance shorter than you think you're capable of doing, especially when you are trying to get into running or come back to running after falling out of love with it.
是的，目标是存在的，但如果你觉得“你应该做到，否则你罪有应得，没有任何解释或借口的余地”，看着你自己以最快的速度对这件事失去兴趣吧。这是我们在任何一个空间、任何一种爱好或生活中的任何领域一次又一次看到的情况。如果属于后者，我想请你休息一下，试着回归身体的自然节奏和身体的自然欲望循环，只有在真正想跑、并且对此感到兴奋时才去跑。并且永远跑一个比你认为自己能力范围短的距离，特别是当你正试图开始跑步，或者在对跑步失去热情后重新开始时。
Also, just just like a random side note tip to beginner runners, you can run as slow as you want. Like, you could literally walk and run and walk and run, and that is still a run. Like, that is the biggest tip I give people when they're like, how, how are you running that much? And I'm like, because I literally run so slow that sometimes people overtake me with their strollers. Like, the other day I was at the park and a child, capital C, child, like, who was literally probably five, lapped me twice, twice. I don't know if it's even healthy that this child was running that distance.
另外，给初跑者提一个小建议，你可以随心所欲地跑得慢。你可以 literalmente（字面意思上）走跑结合、走跑结合，那依然是一场跑步。这真的是我给那些问我“你怎么能跑那么多”的人的最大建议。而我会说：因为我跑得实在太慢了，有时推婴儿车的人都能超过我。就在前几天，我在公园里，一个小孩，大写C的小孩，大概也就五岁左右吧，套圈了我两次，两次。我都不知道这个小孩跑那么远到底健康不健康。
Maybe I was just so slow. They really only did two laps. But yeah, like, who cares? Like, if you're putting one foot in front of the other and you're lifting your feet, like you are running. As long as you're excited to do it, you are running well. Also, just rethink your relationship to fitness apps, Strava, things like that. I've been really loving the podcast maintenance phase at the moment.
也许只是我太慢了吧。他们其实也只跑了两圈。但话又说回来，谁在乎呢？只要你迈开双腿向前走，只要你在抬脚，你就是在跑步。只要你对它感到兴奋，你就是在好好跑步。另外，重新审视你与健身应用程序（如Strava等）的关系。我最近非常喜欢播客《Maintenance Phase》。
It's like a, it's, I don't really know what kind of podcast is. It's like a science, cultural podcast about diet culture. And I think they did an episode recently about like dieting apps and fitness apps and apps like Strava and how if you really want to do something long term, don't rely on those apps to bring you a sense of control over the action or to bring you a sense of achievement. So that is another thing. Maybe go for a realm without your Apple Watch or your Garmin. and also don't let a bad run or a miscession trigger self-criticism or guilt.
它是一个，它，我其实不知道它算什么类型的播客。它是一个关于减肥文化的科学文化类播客。我想他们最近出了一集，讲的是减肥应用、健身应用以及像Strava这样的应用程序，以及如果你真的想长期坚持做某件事，千万不要依赖那些应用程序来带给你对行动的掌控感或成就感。所以这是另一件事。也许不要带着Apple Watch或Garmin去跑步。同时，不要让一次糟糕的跑步或状态不佳触发自我批评或内疚感。
Having flexibility towards running, especially in a group situation, is really crucial for long-term enjoyment and really crucial for avoiding burnout. And finally, I want to leave you with this huge, huge point. Just show up. You absolutely do not need the latest most expensive shoes. You do not need the trendiest athletic wear. I wear my A&U women's department shirt that has multiple holes in it, and I'm pretty sure has snot in it somewhere.
对跑步保持灵活性，尤其是在集体跑步的情况下，对于长期享受乐趣以及避免倦怠至关重要。最后，我想留给你这个非常非常重要的观点。只要出现就行。你绝对不需要最新、最贵的鞋子。你不需要最时髦的运动服。我穿着我的A&U女装部门买的衬衫，上面有好几个洞，我甚至敢肯定上面某处还有鼻涕。
And I'm still running, and I'm still doing the physical exercise, the way that thousands of people before me and my ancestors have probably done. Like, there is so much amazing high-tech gear. It doesn't make you a real runner, and you don't need it to join a run club. the true and only entry requirement is simply just showing up. And I think a lot of new runners feel intimidated by the level of professional gear and how amazing and incredible some people are in the community. Like you've got to remember they have been doing this for a long, long time.
但我依然在跑步，我依然在进行体育锻炼，就像我之前的成千上万的人和我的祖先可能做过的那样。市面上有很多惊艳的高科技装备，但这并不会让你成为一个真正的跑步者，你也不需要它们来加入跑步俱乐部。真实且唯一的入会要求，仅仅是出现。我认为很多新跑步者被专业装备的水平以及社群里某些人的惊人表现所震慑。你必须记住，他们已经坚持做了很长很长的时间。
And each of us has a different relationship with exercise and sport. The social benefits, the physical benefits, the emotional benefits, they are coming not from the running but from the participation. They are going to occur regardless of your pace, regardless of your equipment, regardless of your attire. Just focus on it as a form of connection, not on aesthetics.
我们每个人与运动和体育的关系都各不相同。社交带来的好处、身体带来的好处、情感带来的好处，都不是来源于跑步本身，而是来源于参与。它们都会发生，无论你的配速如何，无论你的装备如何，无论你的着装如何。专注于将其作为一种连接的形式，而不是美学。
And if you feel judged for what you're wearing or your pace, you don't need to be there. You don't need to be there. There's a huge boom in the amount of run clubs out there. There is no shortage of other ones that you can attend. And ultimately run clubs are incredible examples of third spaces and incredible examples of parallel play and of community and of our desire for connection and so many other things. They only bring you joy and will only have benefits if you actually enjoy them.
如果你因为自己的穿着或配速而感到被评判，你就不需要待在那里。你完全不需要待在那里。现在的跑步俱乐部数量正在呈井喷式增长。其他你可以参加的俱乐部数不胜数。归根结底，跑步俱乐部是“第三空间”、平行游戏、社群、我们对连接的渴望以及其他许多事物的绝佳范例。只有当你真正享受它们时，它们才会带给你快乐并带来益处。
So also I've been sitting here being like, these are amazing. If you don't like running and if you don't want to join a run club, you also can find this in other places. It's really the fact that it's a joint activity that is so powerful. So Pilates, boxing, I don't know, rock climbing, craft nights, very similar as well. Okay. Guys, I think that's the end of this episode. Oh my gosh.
所以我也一直坐在这里想着：这些都很棒。如果你不喜欢跑步，也不想加入跑步俱乐部，你也可以在其他地方找到这种感觉。真正充满力量的，其实是它是一项共同参与的活动这一事实。所以普拉提、拳击、我不知道，攀岩、手作之夜，其实也非常相似。好了。伙计们，我想这一集到这里就结束了。天哪。
I feel like I have just gone on for so long. I don't know when I got, like literally the fact that I made almost in one hour long episode I'm running is wilds me. And if you told me that 12 months ago, I would have been shocked. So thank you for joining me for this episode. If you've made it this far, leave a little running emoji in the comments below. So I know you are a loyalist. I want to thank our research assistant Elizabeth Colbert for her incredible contributions to this episode
我觉得自己刚刚唠叨了太久。我都不知道我怎么会——字面意义上，我竟然录了一期将近一小时关于跑步的节目，这让我自己都觉得疯狂。如果你在12个月前告诉我这些，我一定会惊掉下巴的。所以感谢你收听这期节目。如果你坚持听到了这里，请在下面的评论区留下一个跑步的小表情。让我知道你是忠实听众。我要感谢我们的研究助理伊丽莎白·科尔伯特（Elizabeth Colbert），感谢她对本期节目的不可思议的贡献，
with help and inspiration from Angela Chen. Both of them are amazing. Thank you for their contributions. Make sure to share it with a friend. Share it with your running club if you feel called to do so or share a post on Instagram so we can repost on our stories at that psychology podcast. That is the best place to connect with us if you want to see what's coming up. If you want to come to a meetup, if you want to suggest episodes, if you want to give feedback any of those things I'd love to hear from you. But until next time, stay safe, be kind, be gentle with yourself. Go and join the run club and we will talk very, very soon. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available.
以及来自安吉拉·陈（Angela Chen）的帮助和灵感。她们两个都太棒了。谢谢她们的贡献。一定要分享给朋友哦。如果你有共鸣，可以分享给你的跑步俱乐部，或者在Instagram上发个帖子，这样我们就可以在@thatpsychologyypodcast的快拍上转发了。如果你想了解接下来有什么活动、如果你想参加线下聚会、如果你想推荐节目话题、如果你想提供任何反馈，这是与我们联系的最佳地方，我很期待听到你的声音。但在此之前，请注意安全，保持善良，对自己温柔一点。去加入那个跑步俱乐部吧，我们很快就会再聊。百分之二。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人的比例。
I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side, a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWA% on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析精神坚韧、健身以及在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中建立韧性的科学。经历一些磨难，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听《2%》。也就是IHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方的“TWO percent”。
On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84's big to me. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s.
在《Look Back at it》播客中。从1979年开始，这对我和我来说是一个巨大的时刻。84年对我很重要。我是萨姆·杰伊。我是亚历克斯·英格利什。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何熬过这段时期的。与我们的朋友、同为喜剧演员的同行以及最喜欢的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔谈论80年代。
Before it was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor.
在那之前那是一个疯狂的年份。那是一个疯狂的年份。我不认为对黑人来说还有比这更重要的一年了。请在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back at it》。嘿，大家好，你们收听的是《Learn the Hard Way》，我是你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人科尔·盖恩斯。这个空间是关于黑人男性的经历，进行在任何地方都无法真正安全进行的诚实对话，但你是与一位知道自己在做什么的持证专业人士一起交流。有多少男人带着一身盔甲。
It signals to the world that you're not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of bothering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct? I doctored the test once. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern.
它向世界发出信号：你是不好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要去使用它。请在AHA Radio应用程序、Apple Podcast或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Learn the Hard Way》。2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控骚扰双胞胎。但这似乎是一场骗局。你曾两次篡改了这个特定的测试，欧文斯女士，对吗？我篡改了一次测试。这动用了大批互联网侦探才破了案。
Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian. Michael Mancini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
另外两个经历过同样事情的男士。格雷格、一个同性恋者。迈克尔·曼奇尼。我的大脑都要炸了。我是斯蒂芬妮·扬。这是《Love Trapped》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警方。随着节季的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临了后果。请在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。
This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
这是一档IHeart播客。真人保证。本期节目暂无评论。点击转写文本中的任意句子即可留下评论。